Take down competence.
That's fundamentally the underground motivation is to blur the line between
competence and power.
And then to make anyone who manifests any competence feel as if they're doing
nothing but manifesting tyranny.
And it's a terrible doctrine.
And I've seen it really destroyed people.
I literally,
I've seen it destroy people.
And in what context?
Well,
if you're punished every time you do anything forthright and courageous and
noble,
buy,
buy as a consequence of accusations of tyranny and oppression,
then everything you do that's good is punished.
And there's Nicha pointed out,
if you really want to punish someone,
you punish them for their virtues,
not for their faults.
If you really want to hurt someone,
if I punish you because you've done something wrong and you know you've done
something wrong,
you might not be happy punishment.
Well,
but at least it sets the scales right and that Starsky Dostoyevsky's steam in
his great novel crime and punishment.
You know,
where,
where the murderer actually cries out to the heavens to be punished because it's
the only way that he can reestablish his humanity.
But if you really want to hurt people,
then you punish them for their virtues.
And we're definitely in this situation and I think the universities have played
a major role in this were forthright action on the part of ambitious and
productive individuals is confused with tyrannical oppression.
And a lot of that's a consequence of the disturbed relationships between,
well many of the people who take that tack in the social activist domains in
universities and have never had a healthy relationship with someone who
masculine.
And so they feel that masculinity and itself is toxic,
which is that's,
that's what I was going to ask you next because the first video that really
hooked me,
it spoke to me personally,
both as a new father at the time and perhaps also as a,
as a song of a deceased father.
Uh,
it was where you were talking about the relationship one has with his father.
Um,
can you please elaborate a little bit on that?
Well,
the proper role of a father and a mother as well,
although the roles aren't identical.
I would say the,
the proper fundamental maternal role is one of protection.
And the reason for that is quite obvious is that newborn infants need above all
to be protected.
The proper response to an infant's distress is,
you're right and I'll take care of you right now,
especially for the first nine months of life.
There's no disputing that whenever the infant is upset,
he or she needs to be dealt with as if that upset is justified.
But then as the infant matures,
and even by the age of nine months,
I would say then that that has to be,
that,
that that interaction has to be made more sophisticated because the child has to
be encouraged to take his or her place in the world.
And I would say that encouragement is more on the masculine side of the,
of the,
of the duty distribution.
And their father's fundamental role is to produce a bounded environment in which
exploration can take place with an eye towards the encouragement of the child to
develop more and more competence to push that development.
Because,
and it's true for mothers and fathers that the end goal is to produce a person
who's capable of operating autonomously in the world.
Now father's role is to foster that sense of confident autonomy by by
encouraging the child to push his or her limits and like that role can be played
by mother or father if it's a masculine role.
It doesn't have to be played by a man,
but it's,
it's still tilts in that direction.
And so for example,
fathers are much more likely to engage in rough and tumble play with their kids,
which is very,
very good for them by the way,
and absolutely necessary and something to be completely encouraged.
Rough and tumble play at is just fooling around wrestling,
wrestling,
physical play because the kids learn while they learn all sorts of things.
It's like they learned to dance.
That's the best way of thinking about it because a confident child understands
the physics of play and you can see this even in said simple things is going
into a park where there's a lot of dogs and the dogs that are well socialized
are very good at acting out playfulness and you can tell the difference between
a growling dog and a mean dog and afraid and dog and a playful dog.
People are very good at making that distinction and a playful dog knows how to
move in a playful manner and so does a playful child.
And that attentive readiness to play is something that's fostered by those play
fight interactions with fathers for example.
And that makes the kid ready in a deep sense to engage with other children.
And it also sets the stage for a,
for a confident physicality and out in,
in adolescents and in sexual relationships.
I mean,
and,
and so,
yeah,
because a lot of our wisdom is embodied when you,
when you wrestle with kids,
then they learn what hurts them and what doesn't.
They learn how far they can be extended and stretched the limits.
He tests the limits they learned to trust because you throw kids up in the air
and you catch them and you push them to the point where they're really excited.
So they're right on the edge of fear.
Actually.
The excitement pushes right to the edge of fear and but they learn and then they
also learn how they can interact with someone else physically and what's
acceptable and where the limits of pain are.
And what's frightening and what can be sustained and how to take turns and all
of that.
And that's,
it's not abstract,
it's concrete.
It's right in the body.
And so,
so that's part of the father's role.
But the fundamental paternal role is that of encouragement.
And the encouragement is you can handle it kid life is hard.
It's going to come at you and all sorts of ways.
You can accept that as a challenge.
You can thrive,
you can master it and I'm behind you.
Like I'm behind the best in you manifesting itself in the world.
And that gives a kid a spine,
you know,
metaphysically and physic.
And so it's an unbelievably important thing to do.
And fatherlessness is a catastrophe.
If you look at the epidemiological literature,
the psychological literature,
fatherlessness predicts all sorts of terrible outcomes.
It's not good.
And we've fallen into this idea in our society that fathers aren't necessary.
It's like,
and it's just a family that's run by single mother is just as good in in the
broad sense as a family with two parents.
And it's simply not true.
All the evidence suggests.
Now,
that doesn't mean that there aren't single parents who were notably raising
their children because there are,
but in the aggregate,
the two parent family is a much better arrangement for children.
She said that,
uh,
without the encoder Smith off the father,
is this as if it's spirit will be left outside the walls of civilization?
Yes,
that's exactly,
that's exactly it is that,
you know,
the father's role is to,
to,
to note that the individual is capable of thriving in a difficult world and to
put that message forward and to,
and to note that that's been the message of people who've been successful
throughout history and that each individual is capable of doing that,
at least to some degree and has no better bet.
That's the,
as no better alternative.